last night's debate makes Dumb and
Dumber look like Citizen Kane some call
it a disaster others a train wreck even
the National Institute of dumpster fires
has weighed in quote please do not
mention dumpster fires in the same
breath as that debate the debate was far
worse glad we got that quote so how bad
was it this bad will be litigating this
all year I think we were talking about
mass and it doesn't take two hours why
am i stopping no one else stops you
could honor the rules of the debate
thank you my turn
it ask respectfully if you would all
please try to keep to the giardia I've
seen more order in a prison riot
the constant over-and-under talking
created an apt metaphor for the dams a
daycare center with no supervision and
no diapers now intra-party debates
require infighting but I are they in the
same party really they were like
different species exchanging battle
cries sadly the most capable adult could
barely tell a joke I really am surprised
that all of these my fellow contestants
up here I guess would be the right word
for it given nobody pays attention to
the clock I'm surprised they show up
because I would have thought after I did
such a good job in beating them last
week that they'd be a little bit afraid
to do that it was sad not as sad as
watching him apologize to a leftist for
curbing crime because once you do that
they smell blood and then there's no
forgiveness only punishment unless
you're an actual criminal but those
aren't the big problems it's way worse
that wasn't a debate it was a launch
party on the Titanic last night you saw
the opposition toxin at work where every
idea is positioned as a versus be men
versus women black versus white gay
versus straight so when you talk about
uniting a country it's met with a smirk
you
Unity means patriotism which is really
oppression driven by bigotry incapable
of uniting behind American ideals in
free markets and free minds they shout
about how everything how bad everything
is even when things are great but things
aren't great for everyone they'll tell
you true but you're divisive message
only makes things worse for people who
want to do better and who are trying to
do better
that's the oppositional mindset every
answer ends with off with their heads
the only way you can do better is if
someone does worse they've even managed
to politicize a global virus that's not
a message it is a virus and they're
stuck with it all right Katie what were
yet what were your favorite moments well
I think what you saw last night was look
for date last night or four days I'm
from South Carolina a week out from
Super Tuesday this was thrashing that
over talking people interrupting each
other not sticking to the rules was a
preview of dying thrashing campaigns
this was the last stop for people like
Elizabeth Warren Amy Klobuchar mayor
Pete they're done if they don't get any
kind of boost out of this debate and as
we've seen debates haven't really paid
off in terms of support for other people
but I thought Elizabeth Warren had the
weirdest attack of the night when she
went after Mayor Bloomberg for allegedly
telling and employ a female employee to
kill her baby when she was pregnant
which kind of took away the last
argument on the abortion issue so like
on one hand she's saying it's abortion
was not killing but then she accuses
Michael Bloomberg of telling an employee
to kill her baby which I thought that
Democrats were about choice it's just
like a very weird thing for her to say
and certainly didn't get her anywhere
going into the South Carolina on
Saturday yeah and they've never been
able to back up that claim anyway want
what's it CBS's fault or the Dems fault
for that chaos well I think it cbi
should have been able to see something
was quite predictable which is this is
the last debate before Super Tuesday
it's not only South Carolina Super
Tuesday and so there are a bunch of
people as Katie was just laying out who
see this as their last shot to make
their case before the big vote not only
South Carolina but Super Tuesday as I
was saying so to me understanding that
these people are desperate
and that they're hungry and that they're
gonna claw yeah spit and fume they
should have had better you know
guardrails to make sure that there
wasn't the overt I mean here at this
table I think we make an effort not to
over talk because the audience gets
angry the audience doesn't like it
exactly and I think it comes across as
you know lacking not only in decorum but
in effectiveness if you're trying to
deliver a message so I think that that
that's a mistake I mean what could they
have done I mean you think about maybe
you don't need moderators in some cases
lincoln-douglas didn't have a moderator
but i would say that you know they
should have been they should have been
very clear about lanes and times maybe
bells and whistles boxes right Fox has
done the whistles and had to do it
actually in 2016 with the Republicans
yeah electric shocks with electric
that's you know that's what we got to
get you to be this was like watching
people fight over what kind of coffin
they're gonna be buried in I went back
and looked at past debate highlights
from other cycles to see what I was
missing
and Rubio Cruz Christie Romney all of
these people would decimate any one of
these people that we saw last night just
imagine what Trump would do it's like a
heavyweight versus a featherweight
Bernie Sanders doesn't even win the
debate he just gets to the left of
everybody and pounds the podium he has
no depth of knowledge about his own
proposals everything is so thin you
punch him one time and he just says
billionaire I mean that's not gonna last
he's gonna get eaten alive eventually
Mike Bloomberg has no personality
he just memorizes talking points and
delivers him like a robot I've never
seen anybody so rich and successful bomb
like that before be a boss then there's
Biden who I guess was more vigorous but
he didn't have any macho moments he gets
run over by a moderator it's the most
pathetic thing I've ever seen Warren is
the most annoying person I think I've
ever seen on television
she's intolerable and I have a very high
tolerance level yeah
yeah and she's right now all she says is
we need we need we need we need it's
like a verbal tic that doesn't stop
she's now running for second place which
is pathetic
Bernie's attack dog she played the
gender card on him went down in flames
and now she's just carrying his water
Pete is the best debater but he's a boy
I mean he looks like a child out there
he frames an issue very concisely but he
doesn't ever punch above his weight
class every time he tries to hit one of
the big dogs
he gets talked over Amy lost her sense
of humor where did that go and Stiers a
passionate guy but he's like a lizard
it's so hard to look at you can't take
him seriously I just think that a lot of
this stuff that you know we we have been
saying we want them to fight they should
be fighting out there so they're
fighting but they're not but then the
thing that really struck me is comes
back to something Katy was saying when
they like the thing about the baby you
know yes I think even if it by the way
Bloomberg didn't say it was false he
just said I didn't say that but let's
say know what but to me no no because
then remember the what would have been
false is to say that it hurt being fired
from the school because she said she was
pregnant he never said that was false
thats what I'm talking yeah yeah but to
me the fact that it gets thrown out
there is so damaging to bloom so damaged
and similarly the whole racist thing
about the guns and and Sanders you know
he's getting annihilated up well I don't
I was getting annihilated cuz I think
he's doing pretty well in this contest
Leslie well I mean awed by debating let
me think his whole success is based on
money and all might speaking of ads Dana
what was the worst thing I mean what not
worst the weirdest it most surreal thing
I've never seen a campaign ad during a
debate did you see that okay so anyway
I'll forget about them but we should
talk about Bloomberg had an ad and the
debate I think it's vault it but then
why don't they all do it well they don't
have the money for me that's an
expensive ad so does this all help I
mean like doesn't this just make Trump
look better when you see all of this Oh
to Juan's point it's true they got to
have they got a fight but it just makes
them look smaller any well all incumbent
presidents look better during the
primary of the other party because she's
like well gosh I mean you might not like
him but at least there's this that and
then the other thing I mean so I think
incumbent presidents have such a great
advantage a friend of mine teaches at a
major university and he said that
Elizabeth Warren reminds him of the
students he likes the least and then
last night I at because I did the book
signing with Martha I asked Peter to
take some notes for me and he this is
what he had for Tom Styer this is not
like it's kind of Jesse's mom text not
as funny but it says Tom Styer the man
has all the presidents of a wet tissue
blaming the Senate for the fact that gun
control cannot be done nobody considers
the fact that Obama had both the House
and the Senate and I think when Katie
said that they're going after each other
but they're not talking about like it's
so superficial right there's no like
actual debate about okay well what would
you actually do what are the issues that
you would deal with but Biden we've got
very good news today with the
endorsement from Jim Clyburn
and the Palmetto State poll like the
Palmetto poll and which was the most
accurate one for South Carolina in 2016
said Biden is up 35 Wow the next one is
steyr at 17 and Bernie at 13 so this
race could still be way out of whack
because Biden could win South Carolina
doesn't have a lot of money to compete
in Super Tuesday he just did buy some
ads for Super Tuesday but I got to tell
you California is there and Bernie is up
way up